what's going on it's Travis Thompson and
you can catch me on the bootleg Kev
podcast
bootleg cat podcast we got a special
guest here my guy all the way from I
forget what part of uh the Seattle area
I mean I'm technically from Burien
Washington okay
yeah but Seattle [__] yeah hell yeah
hell yeah welcome sir uh you got a new
project out with uh shout out to Jake
one who's another Seattle Legend wills
and white Seas yeah I don't know yeah
he's a bro sound like him yeah it's a
legendary moment bro how were you able
to put like I just feel like he's like
an elusive figure yeah no he is kind of
like tucked in the crib but now like he
I remember he tapped in way back early
because he he thought it was funny we
were representing biryan it was like one
part of the city he's from the same part
no no he's from he's from like the
Central District okay Seattle and that's
like where most of the rappers were from
but then someone was rapping beer and he
thought that she was tight so he like
came out to a show hella hella early so
he's done a few beats for me over the
years but then like we just go to like
random like Seahawk games or like to a
Wale show together or something you know
what I'm saying like so it's just it's
just been the homie for a while and then
decided to do a tape you feel me uh were
you like did you ever listen to White
Band music back in there oh yeah hell
yeah everyone did they still play like
just at the All-Star game they play
white van music like at the stadium oh
[__] yeah like they still got love for
Jake one up there how many people were
at the All-Star Game it was all the way
sold out I just don't know about you
know I didn't hear like there's no hip
hop you're a baseball hater well there's
no hip-hop Buzz about the baseball
All-Star Game Jack Harlow did like the
of course Jack Harlow yeah and then 24
Macklemore there no he wasn't there but
they played can't hold us the real
question is
Two Chains there no two short was there
was a little baby there no a little baby
was not there it was Dirk there no there
were some very popular YouTubers
laughs yeah for sure yeah I don't know
it was cool there was like Hey Edgar
Martinez was there man Felix Hernandez
was there that's all I needed man Ken
Griffey Ken Griffey was there for like
all weekend doing all this [__] he was
like I feel like if the All-Star game is
in Seattle Ken Griffey Jr has to be
everywhere like yo yeah no he he was
everywhere Ichiro back in Japan no he's
he's in Seattle he lives there I believe
he's part of the coaching staff oh [__]
he'd be showing up to the games like
fully suited up bro and I'm like just
hop in there bro like a signature never
from Ichiro he's hard if you ever get
any signatures yeah hell yeah I went to
my I had like a rich homie back in the
day who took me to what's his name Quan
no yeah his name was not quite no but he
he took me to Peoria Arizona for the uh
spring training training yeah so I got a
bunch of signatures back then yeah I got
like that like a Dan Wilson signature
and [__] like you know what I'm saying
like exactly like a bunch of old ass
Mariners never Ichiro though because he
like didn't like do things spring
trainings yeah you're you're really with
the [__] I'm really a mariner Fan Man
unfortunately it's a hard it's a hard
life so rank your Seattle fandom rankage
it'd probably go like Mariners onehawks
yeah I mean I was obviously a Sonic fan
but they left and I was like what eight
or nine and so it's like I never really
like I went to like four or five games
they might come back yeah no I think
they definitely are coming back because
the hockey team had to do well for the
for them the cracking and the Kraken
super lit name and lit logo bro and they
got and they went hella far this season
and they're like a second year expansion
team yeah the uh they're they're I think
that that's one of the hardest names bro
I'm telling you it's fire in the stadium
is the arena is fire bro like it's the
cracking or lit what about the hawk or
the there's the soccer team is it the
sounds yeah it probably yeah probably go
like
Mariners Seahawks
Sonics and then cracking and Sounders
damn yeah you're [__] with a team
that ain't even there I know bro I don't
know it doesn't exist over this hockey
yeah look I stay man I'm just not a
hockey guy but I [__] with the Kraken
though like it's a fire Stadium I'd
rather [__] up the Kraken than the crack
for sure yeah they're cracking it bro
yeah the Kraken is crazy they have the
big ass dragon come down every game what
is a kraken is it it's an octopus yeah
or like I said dragon I'm high do you
think it's like an octopus Seattle has
the best seafood
um I think yeah Seattle definitely has
the freshest Seafood but a lot of it is
[__] bro a lot of these like people
come to town all the time trying to like
get like they're like I need some salmon
bro and I'm like these restaurants this
is like farm salmon and they're just
plating and giving it to you hella nice
like this is not like so where do you go
do you have to go to the market you
gotta go to the markets and just get
some fresh salmon or even Costco got
better salmon than like half these good
restaurants expensive restaurants
because there's like that popular Fish
Market yeah yeah Pike Place Market yeah
but no I've been there once actually
bracket that [__] is super cracking bro
no no pun intended but yeah no no it's
in Seattle though you got to get like
Teriyaki you're like bro you ever heard
of Seattle Teriyaki um
Teriyaki from like you know you've never
had teriyaki down there bro like there's
Seattle Teriyaki is like it's its own
thing and it's the best teriyaki what
makes it unique because it's like it was
made by like Japanese immigrants to
Seattle so it's like it's like it's its
own thing like you can't get it anywhere
else in the country I promise you like
no other Teriyaki is like good uh you're
fully independent now yeah I am fully
independent now what's was it I mean you
were you were I mean I'm working with
them I'm rocking with stem so it's like
it looks like a distro yeah yeah I heard
it's like a very uh interesting like the
approach to distribution yeah it's dope
bro it's really it's almost like Venture
capitalism but like music but it's dope
bro like it's real it's still
independent [__] though like it's no
money going on like people can invest in
your music yeah like if I was like hey I
got 20 grand to put in on this project I
don't know if I mean I don't work it
like that I'm not like the wrestler or
nothing but like yeah like I think yeah
no no for sure I'm just saying like I
don't know how that now but it's it's
real it's just like giving putting money
up for a project and then like a very
small amount they have to make back and
then they're good to go and then they
don't make money on it forever which is
a great deal it's a fire deal bro it's
like I love it stem is cool as [__] they
let me like they don't they just do
whatever we ask really how do you how do
you like uh because you were on Epic for
I was on Epic for four years like two
and a half years yeah [__] yeah it was
it was it was a minute but yeah and it
was tight I I I'm not complaining about
it I would never say like they did me
wrong by any means but it's just a slow
process bro like I can't
especially if like into a label bro
everything is like has to be swing for
the fence like this is the next thing
and it's like bro I'm not even asking
for hella money to enter this song Let's
just let me put songs out in there can I
just put out some [__] today it was just
my fans fed exactly and it was just
static every time and I'm like this
feels Antiquated bro like yeah this is
not a formula for like especially if you
came in to the label repeating doing
something that frequently doing
something that works and then you stop
doing that and everyone's like why why
isn't it working dude like you know what
I'm saying like but I I'm it was good
people and [__] it was just a slow
process bro like I can't do it no more
gotta stop the interview to tell about
our good Folks at Odd Socks baby yeah
shout out to odd talks now this is what
I love about odd stocks one they're
family we love them but also they have
the most comfortable socks in the
[__] world all right now look they
got the craziest licenses you see the
Jolly Rancher these are actually flies
[__]
some Dorito socks uh they got the WWE
license which is just my absolute
favorite and then um personally my
favorite is the odd Sox Basics now these
are just the basic socks so these are in
my bag because I'm taking these
I love these odd Sox basics
these are literally the most comfortable
socks in the world
all right these are just the plain guys
all right also they got the Scarface
they got the Godfather and they have
underwear
what are we talking about what are these
2XL Reese's Pieces you know if uh
somebody was gonna wear some Reese's
underwear I'd assume they'd be a 2x on
the size you know shots of the
Ghostbusters
um look so much going on at Odd Socks uh
what you got to do is go to
oddsocksofficial.com use that promo code
bootleg and you will save 20 off at
checkout all right it don't matter what
you're into they got all the licenses
Coca-Cola you could be a Pepsi guy
instead they got both you know what I'm
saying uh you're into maybe some anime
they got all the anime licenses they got
Naruto they also got um they just uh uh
rolled out the new uh Power Rangers
Transformers all that oddsoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg save 20 off
right now oh my goodness let me tell you
something the best part about my bookie
is not only is it the best sports book
period I mean look we're in the middle
of baseball season and baseball season
is Big Money season if you are a gambler
you know baseball is where you get the
Shmoney all right not only that but they
got the full-fledged casino going on all
right I'm telling you last night I'm on
my bookie I'm playing roulette with a
lady I'm looking at the lady she's on
video she's rolling the wheel it's a
movie all right they got Blackjack they
got uh whatever you're into Blackjack
craps oh man all kinds of slots some of
these slot games are so fun all right
listen everything you want all on one
site mybookie.ag this is the best part
when you sign up with our promo code
bootleg not only do you help us out but
you help yourself out because you're
gonna get that first deposit bonus money
to gamble with immediately free once you
sign up
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
get the first deposit bonus right now
let's get back into the interview uh all
right so the album with Jake one is out
yep and what's it called it's called
wolves and white tees yeah but we got
hella [__] coming out like I got another
album with this guy named Nema schemes
who's done a bunch of my like OG music
we got another one coming out very soon
I'm just about to like run it up bro
you're gonna run it up put a bunch of me
and logic are working on some [__] yeah
you in logic yeah he's about to produce
some a tape for me bro logic is actually
people don't know he's like really just
like fire [__] he's a dope producer
producer yeah bro like the Beast and by
the way his last album might be his I
mean I loved his first album so much but
this last album might be his best album
yeah bro no he's rapping bro he's on his
[__] bro he's on his [__] bro like yeah
no he's cool he's cool as [__] he just
took us on the review out for a few
shows it was tight yeah his fans are
crazy to do like does he like try to
like convince you to play video games
against him so he can embarrass you no
but he I will say he asked me I went to
the studio back in the day and he asked
me if I played chess and I was like nah
and he was like it was definitely like
I've never seen someone so bummed that
to find out you know what I'm saying no
I don't bro and you're like he was just
like oh I [__] him he's like yeah you
are hell you know what I'm saying bro I
was like damn bro like bro we can't play
UNO bro you know it's crazy though
because like we played those of them in
my photographer was like yo do you want
to play chess like oh let's play chess
right now and he busts out a board and
they're just playing chess like like
that and I'm like damn these guys really
do this [__] you know he's serious about
that and uh I feel like he's in video
game [__] but I'm not a video game I
know I look I feel like I look like a
video you definitely look like you've
played a lot of games in your life Jesus
Christ no yeah no I'm not a video game
guy at all bro like I don't miss that
window I mean I play like Skate 3 in GTA
for fun but right but you're not like
you were never like a gamer [__] no just
chugging Mountain Dew at the house no
dude I'm fat off like say my parents are
chefs I'm fat off like Savory food so
it's like you you grew up in a house
with good food yeah and I just ate a lot
of it and then the pizza place by your
house what's the pizza wow how do you
[__] know that's crazy yeah Pizza
Gallery are you yeah the what's funny is
they threw out the first pitch at that
All-Star Game the pizza place yeah they
won like a contest for like best
restaurant or some [__] see that's why
nobody wants to go to the baseball
All-Star Game Jesus Christ he's a
[__] hater because there's [__]
pizza restaurants throwing out the first
pitch white man why is it [__]
contest why can't Macklemore throughout
the first pitch [__] he's done it a few
times he should do it every time did you
see my first pitch though no it was
[__] fire it was right that's why I
didn't see it because if it was horrible
I would have I would have probably heard
about it so I should have threw it out
like like 50 cents that [__] was viral
for like a month yeah you should have
hit try to hit somebody but bro I take
this baseball [__] seriously bro like
this is that's I think that's what I
want to do you should have faked an
injury like you like went to throw it
and you like threw out your pelvis or
something you're like going through it
yeah no that would have went viral for
sure I thought I was feeling like Henry
rolling Garner and just get like a
10-day contract or something yeah I
don't know who that is you ever seen
Rookie of the Year
no it's Rookie of the Year
oh you got my um the kids movie where
you push for the Cubs yeah yeah yeah
yeah I was trying to get the 10-day
contract man that's one of my favorite
baseball movies man but Sam lost the
best one yeah I think sand last the
overall best one but I think rookie of
the year I think no I think well
sandlot's the best kids baseball movie
but I think Bull Durham is the best
baseball movie angel in the Outfield
yeah it's cool that one's basic though
is that the one with the Chris Lloyd the
Angels yeah they don't even know who
Chris Lloyd is
Jesus Christ Christopher Lloyd the guy
who plays [__] the old man in in Back
to the Future oh oh yeah I think that is
him yeah yeah
Yeah Sandlot sandbox the one though
that's my generation uh minor league was
fire what's minor league with Charlie
Sheen
no no about the Cleveland Indians
baseball movie bro it's [__] from
like 1990 it's so far it's got to be
weak and they're like and they're like
[__] terrible like like this team
sucks it's like a team full of like
[__] reads it'd be like if you put
like uh a bunch of uh
I don't know what's what's the show
Eastbound and Down about the baseball
guy I'd be like of a team full of those
you ever watched eastbounded down no
Jesus Christ
damn bro Eastbound and Down is the best
baseball show ever it's on HBO it's a
baseball show it's and it's on HBO it's
starring Danny McBride and it's [__]
hilarious I've never seen this is recent
this is like 2 000 2010 it's what put
him on that's what put him on Eastbound
and Down was like six seasons of comedic
greatness on HBO oh I didn't even know
he plays like this old washed up [__]
like like he had like a stint when he
was like a good pitcher but then he like
[__] crashed out started doing drugs
started beating people up like was in
the tabloids and [__] because then he
finds himself like playing like minor
league baseball in Mexico
okay I bet that sounds that sounds her
though he's just like a piece of [__]
and then he goes and he has to go back
to his his uh he goes and lives with his
little brother so he's like you know
he's like this big Superstar they call
him Kenny power his name's Kenny Powers
but now he lives with his little brother
he's doing like these like shitty like
car dealership autograph signings and
Will Ferrell runs the car dealership
what the [__] yeah I've never seen this
[__] I [__] with Danny McBride too dude
what the [__] one of the best comedic
shows I just started watching that
righteous gemstone [__] that he's into
[__] that you don't [__] with it no it's
good okay no but listen you have to turn
that off and watch Eastbound and Down
because that means you have you have you
have HBO yeah Max yeah you have Max yeah
you just have to go on Max and type in
Eastbound and Down no I promise you I'm
about to do that because I [__] with
baseball it is [__] like it's the
best it's like probably the best comedic
show it's like that or or Curb Your
Enthusiasm in the last like you think
it's like that good yeah it's so [__]
good bro okay you like baseball and you
like Danny McBride it's like and it's
like super like it was like it was
popping like right before this cancel
culture [__] like ruined TV okay and
ruined movies you know that's how you
feel so it's like a great like great
offensive just good harsh comedy Will
Ferrell's executive producer okay Bet
okay yeah no I'm tapped in I'm tapped in
okay Bet hey let's stop the interview
real quick to tell you about our good
Folks at King Palm that's right man
shout out to King Palm uh we're talking
about nothing but that organic all right
that natural
Them Leafs all right there's no tobacco
involved and they're so smooth when you
smoke in them I love King Palms the only
thing I'm smoking out of now if you go
to your local uh liquor store you go to
your local smoke shop you can get King
Palms of course 7-Eleven's got the king
pongs and they have so many crazy
flavors like shout out to Sugar Shawn
who's from um
Phoenix Arizona my hometown he's got his
own flavor they just sent us these now
what's dope about King Palm is that they
have the the terpene infused flavors so
at the end of the tip of these pre-rolls
right you get the Leaf
you squeeze the tip that's what she said
and then you just get a burst of flavor
this is that honey mango all right now
this is the most important part this is
absolutely natural
tobacco-free leaves the cleanest way to
smoke all right trust me when I say it
man we love King Palm over here so many
flavors I mean shout out to the grape
shots of the honey mango shout out to
the sugar punch right here you know what
I'm saying look if you go to kingpom.com
right now you can get hooked up with
everything you need at 50 off if you use
the promo code bootleg or bootleg Kev
try either one of those I forget which
one it is it's bootleg or it's bootleg
Kev you know what the correct promo code
will be down below use the one that's
down here kingpom.com get 50 off right
now shout out to King pong
also want to shout out to our good Folks
at Blue chew baby shout out to Bluetooth
now this was going on with Bluetooth man
everybody keeps asking me this Bluetooth
work yes it works but don't take my word
for it you're gonna get a month for free
when you go to bluetooth.com and you use
the promo code bootleg a month for free
now what is Bluetooth fellas if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction fellas
if your dick is not getting as hard as
you'd like it to maybe for your wife oh
I don't know listen all you got to do is
go to bluetooth.com it has the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
but it's getting delivered to you in a
chewable form right to your door in
discreet packaging and you do not have
to go into a doctor's office to get
Bluetooth you go to bluetooth.com you
use the promo code bootleg you get a
month supply delivered to your door
discretely of course
discreetly no doctor's appointments no
going and leaving your house and sitting
in a Lobby and waiting for some you know
lady to call you in so you could tell
her how your cock's not working properly
it happens fellas all right
blueshear.com take my word for it also
take their word for it because they're
going to give you a month's supply for
free just five dollar shipping
bootry.com promo code bootleg uh let's
get back to the interview
there it is we'll look go get the album
oh yeah go get the album for real
um is there gonna be any like you guys
doing any vinyl or anything oh yeah
we're definitely planning on doing a
vinyl because you know the hip the
rapping Ass Fans want the vinyl ship for
real that's like the bread and butter
for these guys and then uh your when do
you know when the next items come out
with your boy or something yeah this
fall so probably like September October
we're ready to go man like show coming
up in Seattle I got yeah I got I'm in
like Bellingham for a Festival this
weekend new family but yeah no we're
touring for real in the fall like I'm
going on a headline tour I believe nice
yeah just just a few a few days here I'm
saying down the West Coast Denver
Phoenix then head over to like New York
they love you in Phoenix they do love me
in Phoenix but that's like we besides
Seattle we do the biggest shows in
Phoenix they love you man you're a lot
of numbers out there love you bro all my
native homies be like yo you [__] with
Travis time I'm saying damn right you
damn right Arizona is home bro it's nice
we should move there I might I might I I
saw how futuristic I was living and I
was like oh yeah I might have two bro
because he has the two houses next year
and he was like the sun's rapper when I
went out there so he had the sweet he
had the sweet bro he was hard bro he was
living I was like damn this AZ [__] I
don't think do you think the Mariners
would make you the Mariners rapper [__]
now I hope so I hope that one day no
yeah no one day they'll make me the
rapper there I don't I don't think
they're into like having a rapper like
just Macklemore yeah I think Macklemore
could definitely be the Mariners rapper
if he wanted but do you think McLemore
ever been the mayor of Seattle
I think he genuinely wants to do that
but I think he could do it I think he
could I think well I think we've learned
that anyone can do it not to disrespect
Ben but anyone can be a man to be fair
also like Macklemore's one of the nicest
human beings I've ever met so the
sweetest guy I don't give a [__] about
the city no for sure yeah I might I
might vote for him and his last zombie
just dropped us very slept on very fire
yeah yeah hell yeah the homies worked on
it so yeah for real 100 man we'll
appreciate you pulling up we're gonna
have you freaking style YouTube video
Let's Do It Travis Thompson boom hey
this interview is brought to you by our
good Folks at hardean all right shout
out to the hardeen family in Las Vegas
make sure you follow them Harding
underscore Las Vegas the number one
dispensary period all right the craziest
selection of Premium premium cannabis
you could ask for plus when you go to
Hardy in Las vegas.com you can check out
all the other cool stuff they got going
on you know they got a whole weed
University happening in Vegas Hardin is
where it's at all right so if you're in
Las Vegas you get into that taxi cab you
say take me to Jardine and when you get
there you tell the wonderful Bud tenders
that I sent you and they're going to
take care of you Harding underscore Las
Vegas go follow them and uh yeah we got
another interview coming soon